I was told to stock the fridge in the
apartment but I have no idea what you
people eat down deep
children
mostly sometimes each other
the last episode of silos showed that
Jules is more comfortable with machines
than she is dealing with people and you
saw that she left that comfort zone
behind she gave up a life where she only
had to focus on keeping the generator
running and the purpose that gave her to
go looking for answers about what really
happened to George it's why Holston
picked her and he expresses that through
the message he left for her on his badge
he believed he could count on her to
pursue the truth and sending her that
sign implies that he thinks there's
something worth looking for that's the
most obvious place where this episode
gets its name but it relates to almost
everything else that happens here you
get the truth about what happened when
she was a child before she went to work
in mechanical you see how the people in
power try to control information and
reserve the truth on a need to know
basis and that what you know can be
dangerous regardless of the position you
hold finally you see the truth of
Juliet's situation when the mayor told
her she was the only other person in The
Silo that wanted her to be Sheriff she
wasn't exaggerating and now that she's
gone both of her supporters are dead
the episode opens with the flashback to
Juliet's childhood there's a medical
emergency involving her younger brother
Jacob where you see the family pool
together to revive him the way the
family works as a team and the way he
cracks a joke calling Juliet a jerk face
when he comes to indicate that this is
something that they've learned to live
with this hints at what her father
didn't say when Johnson marns asked
about her leaving home so early and in
the present day you see Juliet getting
ready to go see him on her way up the
stairs only to be interrupted by a
porter that was sent to find her she's
being called to the mayor's office where
she finds out what happened to her and
also that her new primary Deputy is
understandably not taking it well he
believes the mayor was killed with rat
poison that was slipped into her water
bottle while they were away from the
deputy station in the mids having their
moment together since you drink from the
other person's pack when you walk The
Silo together he believes that he was
the target for the attack attack and
wants judicial to provide a list of
possible suspects that might have it in
for him based on what they say and
because the mayor was so popular Bernard
and Sims seem more concerned with
managing the news of her passing in a
way that won't get the population
stirred up Jules is pretty much the odd
man out here it doesn't seem like anyone
wants her to be there but as the head of
I.T Bernard takes over as mayor on a
pro-team basis at least until new
elections can be held so he decided to
Loop her in as the incoming Sheriff
because Mars's reaction to her being
there might get wrapped up in him being
upset I think it's worth mentioning that
he never wanted her to have the job
either she gets a less than warm welcome
and her new office she can't even get a
meal after her long trip because who
knows what these people from the down
deep eat you do see a little bit of the
up Toppers prejudice against people from
the lower 50 bleed through in this
conversation between what's happening
with Sandy at the station and basically
everyone else she's come in contact with
you can see that this search for truth
about what happened to George will be an
uphill battle still that's her primary
concern so after she gives about as good
as she gets in her back and forth with
Sandy she asks for his folder the next
flashback scene jumps ahead to a point
where both Juliet's younger brother and
Mom are out of the picture the fact that
he wants her to pack up their things by
herself and take them to recycling while
he's at work hints that her father might
not be up to the challenge of guiding
his daughter through this difficult time
back in the present she takes a look at
the door to outside and holding cell
number three and then goes to check out
her new apartment which is holston's old
apartment when she turns on the air it
reminds you of the first episode where
you saw him doing something to that vent
she finds a card reminding her to turn
in any items from the previous tenant to
recycling and that sets up another
flashback where we see her do doing that
with her moms and her brothers things
which is pretty harrowing when she goes
back to the apartment she starts some
food for herself and then she gets
absorbed in fixing her mother's chair
which is something that her father said
couldn't be done he comes home to the
fire alarm going off and they have some
words it's all pretty regrettable but
she implies that it's his fault the
situation they're in is somehow his
fault but they never explain what
happened or why she feels that way
there's still some mystery there her
brother was obviously ill there was
something going on there but her mother
looked pretty normal the one time we saw
her later on we'll learn that Juliet's
liking to fix things and her decision to
run away to Mechanical is all because
her mother had some connection to these
things when she gets there she passes
Walker a forged note and we get some
younger versions of Knox and Shirley who
we've seen her working with in the other
episodes because she's spelled
mechanical wrong in the no note Walker
sends word to her father so that he
won't think that she just disappeared
and lets him know that she's there when
he arrives she tells him that she likes
the work she likes to work so hard that
she doesn't have time to think about
what happened and I guess based on the
fact that he really doesn't know what to
do with her her father decides to let
her stay it's a little bit strange it
definitely doesn't make you like this
character Dr Nichols very much but it
does make everything that we've seen
about them in the present their
situation their relationship there makes
sense and there's a pretty rough moment
when she leaves without going to him she
doesn't do anything she just sort of
walks out and it felt like a reflection
of her saying goodbye to Walker in the
last episode there was a moment there
where it looked like she didn't know how
to express the feelings she had and
considering that there she does give in
and she puts her head on Walkers back on
the way out that signals that she's been
the parental figure in her life since
she left home which underlines the idea
of what she left behind to take on this
role that nobody wants to see her do
regardless she starts to get settled in
and Sandy tells her that judicial says
they don't have a file on George she
mentions that Holston did leave a file
for the next Sheriff though and inside
of that she finds the note about
doubling the flowers in front of the
mirror before she can look through the
rest of it they get a call that marns is
basically beating up suspects in the
mids he's clearly not taking things well
and Jules sees an opportunity to try to
make an alliance she explains why
Holston picked her and the sign that he
sent and asked him to help her find out
what happened to George in exchange
she'll help him find out what happened
to John's there's a moment in his
apartment where he starts to come around
to the idea in the process she figures
out he was in love with the mayor and he
starts to see that her intentions are
fairly pure she doesn't have an angle
for doing all this she also tells him
that once they solve George's case
she'll leave the position and they can
get somebody else to be Sheriff which
would satisfy any objections he has to
her doing the job before she leaves she
asks him if he wants to put a guard out
front because he pissed off so many
people that it's probably a good idea
but he insists his shotgun will be
enough to scare anyone away there's a
suicide fake out sequence where I
thought for sure he was gonna hang
himself in grief but it turns out to be
him making a punching bag for his
frustrations Sims from judicial comes to
see him and expects him to help push
Jewels out they have a plan the judge is
behind it but because of the
conversations that they've had marns
doesn't want to go along with it and
when Sims invokes the judge's wishes he
says that he doesn't work for judicial
from there we see Mars drinking and
feeling bad thinking about the time that
he had with the mayor right before she
died he overhears Jules calling Walker
on the radio they keep their
conversation discreet it's been
established that Walker having a radio
could put her in Jeopardy and that and
he can overhear them might be a clue as
to what's going on with radios in The
Silo in general but even though they're
careful about what they say he still
picks up on the fact that she's looking
at him to be her Ally and you can see
that he's coming around to the idea
after that we get a split scene with the
both of them going back to their
respective apartments inside of Mars's
he finds someone waiting for him and
he's attacked we see that there is a
real struggle there at jules's apartment
she notices the flowers in front of the
mirror and then sets out to find out
what the sound in the event is Mars
almost gets away from his attacker but
then he gets his shotgun and he's left
in a pretty tough position then the
episode ends with Juliet finding
George's file which is what Holston left
for her to discover
I really enjoyed this episode in the
flashbacks there are also a lot of
things that come up in this episode that
sort of slip by but feel like they'll
come back around the guy sitting in the
cafeteria who awkwardly introduces
himself as Lucas later the mention from
the suspect who stopped them outside of
his dead wife's apartment hinting that
Mars was responsible for her death why
Jules blames her father for what
happened at home and seeing Walker
powering up George's camera it was great
to see them pick up on all the Holston
stuff in the opening sequence of episode
1 here which tells you you need to keep
your eyes peeled for details in every
episode it's a really great character
episode as well most of which is at
least hinted at in the books if not
delivered in the exact same way and it's
promising to see them leaning in and
using the medium to flesh out the
characters and their motivations one
thing that bugged me when I first
watched this was that most of the
characters from it and judicial come off
as flat out sinister I know they tried
to add some depth by showing Sims as a
dedicated family man but they all still
have an up to no good disposition that I
didn't love and it's not even that it
doesn't make sense for their roles that
afford them power in this very strange
social order it's more like they elicit
the response okay these are the bad guys
and it ends there although I'll say it's
still early and it might make sense
because the big question is why are they
there in the first place what's going on
with the silo so let's wait and see how
it plays out additionally everyone is so
against Jules in this episode it makes
it easy to overlook how she doesn't do
herself many favors in trying to fit in
not that she has to necessarily and you
do see that she tries to get Mars on her
side which strategically makes sense but
I guess we can't forget that she has a
very clear purpose for why she's there
and she isn't the type of person to make
friends I really like the bit where she
was so distracted by the folder she was
looking at that she just turns down the
radio rather than answering it seeing
what makes her tick is what works best
in this episode and I think Rebecca
Ferguson's ability to pack every
interaction with substance is what
carries it for me when a show deals in
Mysteries these are the episodes that
make her break it the ones that fill in
the blanks in between the big moments
they're asking us to see things from
Juliet's point of view and providing us
the information we need to understand
how she'll navigate the up top as an
outsider four episodes in and there are
a lot of people being taken off the
board which makes Mars's status feel
crucial as far as the book to show stuff
there's not much to report the show
feels very true to Juliet's character
and the development of the questions and
other than some things being presented
at different times or changes that make
for better TV it's very faithful big
picture wise a place where it might be
frustrating for people who've read ahead
is that the books had a very consistent
pace of revealing things which might be
tied to the fact that it started as a
standalone short story but the show
appears to be trying to withhold things
and take a more deliberate approach
keeping the audience closer to where the
characters are in their understanding of
what's Happening overall I think both
versions are fine though and while that
was something that I liked about reading
the books if I had watched the show
first I can't imagine that it would be
an issue the payoffs will come and I
think that they'll probably be the same
so I imagine they'll be equally as
effective last week there was a lot of
talk about the glitching screen and what
was going on outside that naturally
takes a back seat here because we need
to see Jules transition into her new
role her new life in a brand new
surrounding and I'm really excited to
see what happens next so remember there
are some things a shotgun is not the
best solution for and that seems like a
great place to leave things please like
this video If you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already and thanks for watching I'll
talk to you soon